DAVA NEWMAN: We want to make
Earth as habitable and livable,
and since we're
accelerating this change,
we want to live in balance
with Spaceship Earth.
SARAH HANSEN: In
today's episode,
we're taking another look at
our planet from the outside in.
DAVA NEWMAN: Simply
we're trying to design
a healthy relationship
between people, technology,
and our Earth systems for
sustainability of humanity
and all the living
things on the planet.
SARAH HANSEN: I'm your
host, Sarah Hansen.
Today on Chalk
Radio, we're talking
with Apollo Program Professor
of Astronautics Dava Newman.
Professor Newman is an expert
in aerospace engineering,
and she's used that knowledge
to forge new perspectives
on climate change.
You can check out Professor
Newman's course, 16.423J,
Aerospace Biomedical and
Life Support Engineering,
on OCW as well as her
climate-focused resources.
In short, Professor
Newman has worked
on some very cool things,
including better spacesuits
for astronauts, ones designed
for much longer journeys
into space in the future.
DAVA NEWMAN: In research--
I specialize in
astronaut performance
and biomedical
engineering as well.
I spend a lot of time thinking
about humanity becoming
interplanetary literally when
we'll have humans going back
to the moon and Mars,
and design of suits,
and life support
systems, and experiments
to keep our astronauts
healthy and well
during long-duration flight,
and about 50% of my research
is now in climate.
And I kind of frame
that as Earth systems.
As an engineer myself
looking at complex systems,
well, there's no
more complex system
I submit than Earth
systems, and that
includes oceans to land to
air, all the way to space.
SARAH HANSEN: Because of her
background as an aerospace
engineer, Professor Newman
takes a unique approach
to climate change.
Many of her teachings draw on
this approach and the lessons
from her time at NASA.
DAVA NEWMAN: I served as
NASA Deputy Administrator,
so that's the number two
during the Obama administration
from 2015 to 2017.
And most people think of NASA
and think of human spaceflight.
That's my research
specialty and background,
but really, it's
all the aeronautics,
breakthrough research as well,
a huge amount of Earth science
research related to climate.
We have a hundred
science missions
flying at any one time,
exploring the solar system
and beyond, exoplanets.
NASA's always been
my agency, but to be
able to be a leader
at NASA and also join
the civil servants-- that
was really quite an honor,
and it's definitely
changed my research.
And what we're talking
about, climate--
I came back to MIT as the Apollo
professor and said, you know,
what's the most important thing
I can be working on every day?
And my answer changed
after my NASA experience.
Now the answer is climate and
Earth systems, secondarily,
getting people to Mars.
SARAH HANSEN: Part of her
work with Earth systems,
or systems that span our globe
and connect us as a planet,
is helping people understand
this more global perspective.
Professor Newman has
some powerful insights
about organizing
people around this kind
of big-picture thinking.
Her time at NASA coordinating
international efforts
informs her approach to
climate action and research.
DAVA NEWMAN: As an
aerospace engineer,
we have a pretty specific, I
think, special perspective.
It's called the
overview perspective.
So anyone who is an aerospace
engineer-- we're always
looking at data from
satellites and from space,
first the human experience in
space, when the astronaut is
in low Earth orbit, looking down
on Earth, Spaceship Earth as I
call it.
And so we're all on this
Spaceship Earth together.
Guess what.
We're all the crew.
We're actually all
astronauts because we're
orbiting around our sun.
And that's how I think we
need to think about climate
and accelerating positive change
is a-- it's a global issue.
It's an Earth-wide issue, and
I think the overview effect--
you can really look at down
on Earth, get into the data,
but equally as important is
the human spirit and thinking
about collaboration.
It's not a nation-state
issue at all.
We want to make Earth as
habitable and livable,
and since we're
accelerating this change,
we want to live in balance
with the Spaceship Earth.
SARAH HANSEN: Recently,
Professor Newman
co-founded the non-profit
organization called EarthDNA.
It's a global platform for
climate advocacy and action.
EarthDNA works to inform and
facilitate climate action
by first sharing knowledge
about our planet in a way that's
available and
accessible to everyone.
The spirit of teaching
openly and collaboratively
is one that Professor
Newman and her EarthDNA
co-founder, Guillermo
Trotti, care about deeply.
DAVA NEWMAN: We call
EarthDNA our life project.
It's open source, and we really
envision a platform for climate
advocacy and action.
It starts with
knowledge and education.
I've been an educator
my whole life,
so it starts with the
educational piece.
Using a lot of
artificial intelligence.
I call it curating the
data, petabytes of data,
literally data from
our satellites,
so we have so much data.
That gets overwhelming, even for
me as an engineer and scientist
but for sure for someone
who's busy working,
and they just want to know a
little bit more about climate.
We have to-- I call
it-- you curate
that data, use our
artificial intelligence,
use these wonderful
visualizations so people
say, ah, I get it.
I get temperature change.
I get ocean change.
The hard piece, the second piece
is changing human behavior.
So the point about EarthDNA--
simply we're trying to
design a healthy relationship
between people, technology,
and our Earth systems
for sustainability of
humanity and all the living
things on the planet.
We can't waste a second.
We can't waste a day.
It's so urgent in the next
decade to do, I think,
whatever all of we
can through all of us
to really move the bar,
to really accelerate
positive change for the Earth.
SARAH HANSEN: Part of what makes
EarthDNA unique and uniquely
accessible is its focus on
meeting people where they are,
literally.
DAVA NEWMAN: We can talk
about the temperature,
global temperature,
and things like that,
but I think we care
about our own zip code.
We care about our
family and friends.
So what I care about is what's
happening in my backyard here.
I have family in Montana and
California on the West Coast.
We have relatives in Argentina.
So I have those five zip codes,
and what I care about is, oh,
what's happening here?
Maybe what can I
do in those places?
So the point being that we need
to have global information.
We need to zoom down
to maybe regional,
and then we need to
care about local.
And so maybe you love turtles.
Maybe you love things
out in the ocean.
We're trying to be a network
that can connect these things
and give you news that
might be relevant to you.
What's happening
tomorrow, Saturday?
Maybe I can go
join some friends,
and we can do a little bit
of a beach cleanup, something
like that, just
something simple that I
enjoy doing, but
trying to connect
people that are like-minded.
SARAH HANSEN: Professor
Newman and her colleagues
have developed another
powerful strategy
for helping people learn and
engage around climate issues.
They've separated Earth into
four different sub-systems.
DAVA NEWMAN: There's no
silver bullet for climate.
It's really all these complex
systems working together,
so the oceans first and
foremost because the oceans
are our largest sub-system
and then the land,
where most people live, on land,
and then from the land, air,
and then space.
I count space, again,
back to my roots.
I'm biased.
I'm an aerospace engineer.
But that's really where
so much of the information
is coming from, near space,
so our satellites, our eyes
on Earth, the information
that we can see from space
is when we get that
global, that holistic view.
So that's why I put those
four sub-systems there.
We need work in
all of them, but I
think I find it helpful to talk
about those four sub-systems
because someone might
have affinity-- oh, for me
it's the oceans.
Oh, no, for me it's the land.
And that's kind of
the fundamental part
of the mission.
It's to make the world of
work for 100% of humanity.
SARAH HANSEN: An important
part of climate science
is making models that
help us predict what's
likely to happen in the future.
This posed a particularly
complex challenge
for Professor Newman
and the EarthDNA team.
How to convey complex
climate models that
draw on tons of data points
and variables to those of us
who don't have a background
in climate science?
DAVA NEWMAN: We
have so much data
from our satellites
for Earth systems.
Maybe just even take
ocean data, if you will.
Take a look at, well, what's the
sea level temperature, what's
the sea level rise,
coverage of the whole Earth.
And then, again, we want to zoom
down into something regional.
Let's say the North Atlantic.
We can look from,
say, New England,
where we are at MIT, all the
way, then, across the Atlantic,
taking all that data, going
deep into reducing it.
And it can generate satellite
images from the future.
Imagine I could put
that in your hand.
Perhaps if we immerse people
in these future visions or--
boom, teleport yourself to
anywhere you want in the world.
And so it's the
the storytelling,
and the storyline, I
think, hopefully also
will engage people and
get people involved.
And hopefully people can
ask questions and people can
think about, OK, what can I do?
And we can serve
up a whole bunch
of different opportunities,
different actions
that they could take.
Even though a lot of
this is open source,
it's really hard to access.
It takes a lot of time.
It can take an hour of digging,
let's say, on a NASA website
to find what you
might be looking for.
Well, wouldn't that be neat
if you could just speak to me,
and give me a
couple of keywords,
and say what you'd
want, and then, boom,
I'd serve it up now.
We don't have that
capability yet,
but that's what
we're working on.
We want to make it that easy.
SARAH HANSEN: For
this episode, we also
had the chance to ask Professor
Newman some of your questions
that you submitted to us.
One of the questions was this--
does the Earth have
global climate cycles,
and is climate change possibly
just part of a normal cycle?
DAVA NEWMAN: Earth
does have cycles.
Earth is 4.5 billion
years old, and so we've
had weather and climate through
those billions and billions
of years.
So there are cycles,
but no, we are not
in a normal cycle by any
stretch of the imagination.
This is an incredibly
accelerated response
since the Industrial Revolution.
We actually can calculate the
percentage of climate that
is human-caused human-induced.
There's some tools out
there, some simulations.
You can imagine.
Well, what if I use
this much energy?
What if we emit this
much carbon dioxide?
Oh, what if we cut down by 50%?
And what we're striving for
is, where's that balance?
Where's that balance for
people having healthy,
wonderful, again,
economically successful
lives but just always trying to
keep that in mind, our effects
on climate, and how
we can change things,
and how we can do much better.
SARAH HANSEN: Another one
of your questions was this--
how is climate change
transforming people's lives
and societies at a broad level?
DAVA NEWMAN: Climate change
impacts every single one of us,
and it's going to
get more acute.
And it's going to
get more intense.
Globally, we definitely see it,
immigration and people moving.
And people don't ever
want to leave their house.
You want to stay with
your family and friends,
but if you're forced to,
especially by natural disaster,
but especially by war--
but I think that we really
need to show people the
connections between climate
and health.
So again, that's
really important today.
Let's link.
We have the climate data.
We have health data,
but let's link them
because they're
very, very linked.
We can talk about asthma.
We can talk about people's
changing health issues,
and we can look at that and say,
there's a climate link there.
And that's, I think, an
important discussion to have.
SARAH HANSEN: Another
question you submitted was,
what are one or
two of the biggest
challenges that governments and
concerned citizens of Spaceship
Earth should try to solve in
order to prevent or mitigate
climate change?
DAVA NEWMAN: I
love that question,
and my answer is really just
a discussion with that person.
What do you want to do?
Because I think it's
important that people
go with their passion.
There's so much to do.
There's something
that everyone can do,
so I'd like to ask
it back answer,
not to not answer question, but
just to know a little bit more
about that person and
say, what do you like?
What's really your passion?
And then if I know
that, again, it
could be something
for the oceans.
Maybe it's something
for animals,
or land, or something like that.
Maybe it's pollution
and plastics.
So good, we love a challenge.
Well, what's the
plastic in the future?
What's a synthetic biological--
what's the biological new
material-- not plastic,
but new material-- in the
future that acts like plastic?
We probably couldn't
live without plastic,
but let's reinvent it.
Let's reinvent it so that
is completely sustainable.
And there's research
going on that right now,
but hopefully that's
just an example
for someone for that question,
seeing what they like to do
and what they'd like
to get involved in.
SARAH HANSEN: And our last
question from listeners--
how long do we have before
it's too late to do something
about climate change?
DAVA NEWMAN: I'd
like to rephrase
that a little bit and say,
now is the time to act.
No more excuses, no
more pushing this off
onto the other generation.
Everyone can do something today,
and these are little things.
These really are not
inconvenient things.
These are things that I
think everyone actually
would feel good about, so
the time to act is now.
SARAH HANSEN: Thanks
for joining us
for another episode
of Chalk Radio.
We hope you're feeling
inspired and motivated to start
taking some steps to
mitigate climate change based
on your own passions
and interests.
Don't forget to check out
Professor Newman's courses
and her EarthDNA
resources on our website.
You can also visit earthdna.org.
Signing off from
Spaceship Earth,
I'm Sarah Hansen from
MIT OpenCourseWare.
Hey, before we go, did that
OCW has a birthday coming up?
We're turning 20 in April.
For two decades we've worked
to share MIT course materials
with the world.
Your support helps us to
do so freely and openly
and helps make resources
like this podcast possible.
If you're able to
give, please consider
donating to OCW at
ocw.mit.edu so we can stay
open for the next 20 years.
Thank you.
AUDIO BUMPER Ma, park the car.